Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Tanner from Duluth, Minnesota.
Speaker 3: Hello.
Speaker 1: Hello, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Sweet, do I sound good?
Speaker 1: If the beautiful audio,
I have to say awesome.
Speaker 6: Thank you. All right. So in Minnesota,
a lot of a lot of industry goes on here on stuff
like that. And I was just wondering if, you know,
if you noticed all the like strikes and labor
movement going on right now, do you really do
you think that Democrats should be doing more to
support it or support unions? Because I feel like,
you know, back in decades ago, like union people
in unions used to be like hard core Democrat
voters, it seems like unions kind of just kind
of went by the wayside and they don't really care
about them anymore. And a lot of people in unions
actually vote Republican now, especially like in
the trades, which used to be like very, very blue.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you're completely right. So
in terms of the strikes and and making
progress in terms of labor, I think it's
a perfect opportunity we have seen, you know, the
pandemic has been basically horrible in all ways,
but if we if we want to say, Hey, what are
maybe some good things to come from it? One is
the rapid advancement of RNA technology for other
types of vaccines. And now there's all sorts of
different advancement that's happening
there, and it's created this opportunity
in the kind of shut down and then restarting in
many industries for workers to say, Hey, you know,
we're going to come back if and when we get
better conditions, better pay, etc. So I think
the opportunity is an extraordinary one. I would
like to see Democrats be more openly supportive
of unions. I also think it's important to kind
of couch the union discussion in proper context
because there are some people who say, I would
like to see every employee be part of a union.
You know, the truth is with small businesses,
with very few employees being an overwhelmingly
large portion of the work that is out there,
mom and pops with two or three employees, etc.
my opinion is that really doesn't lend itself
to unionization. I think there are other ways
to empower workers there and create a safe safety
net. And you know, some states have put in place
paid medical and family leave regardless of
employer size. Yeah, I think that so I think
our expectations have to be reasonable that at
the mom and pop level, unions are probably not
the future of democratizing labor. There's
other things. But yes, I would like to see
more successes come from the strikes that we are
seeing. I think the timing could not possibly be
better. Leverage is something that has not been
at this level for workers for a really long time,
and I'd like to see Democratic elected officials
be more supportive, for sure. Only sounds good.
All right, thanks, Dana. Appreciate it.
Speaker 6: Yeah, thank you very much,
First-Time Caller. Love your
Speaker 1: show. All right, thank you so much.
There's Tanner from Duluth. What a phone call.
What a phone call. Let's take a very quick break.
But if you're holding, don't hang up because we're
going to go right back to the phones momentarily.